internation very exciting episode this
crew I actually I actually was really
fun when this crew went down the
escalator one is a ridiculously handsome
and famous face to me and I made the
connection very quickly and the other is
like I'm like wait a minute
not as a nerd with this dude like three
years ago he's a real entrepreneur so I
was super excited when they pitched and
I it's been really fun actually got to
see the preview of their episode I
haven't seen the final final final edits
as well as this recording of this
podcast goes I'm gonna allow them to
introduce themselves but in the hundreds
of pitches it was one of the more
memorable ones for me I remember quite a
bit about it and so without a further
ado gentlemen why don't you introduce
yourselves to the vaynernation who you
are a little bit about yourselves and
the app that you guys presented and then
we'll get into the show my name is Damon
Wayans Jr I'm an actor and comedian male
model male model potentially if the
money is right everybody's got a price
everybody does and this is my partner in
crime yeah so I'm Chris Jones serial
entrepreneur investor and I partnered
and we founded an app called special
guest it enables anyone anywhere to
affordably and easily hire live
entertainment I love it
so if I'm having a bar mitzvah yeah and
I need some talent and I'm not some
superstar that's gonna fly in Drake to
do it I can go on the platform and find
kind of Drake for a lot less you can
find the talent of Drake for a lot less
yeah are you saying Drake is not
talented
no no I'm saying I'm saying you can find
a person that is super affordable that
has the talent of Drake you're saying
I'm sleek is commoditized in his talent
that there are so many people that can
perform that skill at a much lower price
[Laughter]
because you are absolutely a serial
entrepreneur you know as I was it's
funny how your brain can do so many
things
you guys are pitching you're doing your
thing I'm like you know I'm trying to
win like you know I can't I have no
other year I'm trying to get the best
companies like I'm
thinking back to a lot of smart things
you said in that Upper East Side I
remembered everything about that meeting
what kind of experience as an
entrepreneur and the serial entrepreneur
has planted the app spin like from that
Hollywood crossover obviously you have a
celebrity partner in this business has
it been a fun journey was that enjoyable
like what should give me your two three
minute recap of the experience you know
I mean coming into it I mean it's it's a
bit of we got a lot of work to do but a
bit of an unfair advantage to be able to
launch an app on the Apple platform
right with the backing of the show with
the backing of all the publicity so you
guys were back at the pad before you
came day one on satellite this is we've
already won the exposure is real or were
you thinking okay we know how they add
at eBay we better get to the next round
or we're gonna get like a quick facial
visual and we're not gonna get [ __ ] from
it
it was both yes yeah we knew we knew
that you know it could potentially go
downhill mm-hmm
but when we got it were you worried that
Asus mentors could have become could
have been cynical to the powerful last
name that you had do you think that we
could have taken the cliche like ah you
don't give a [ __ ] about this absolutely
and I you know I went in there expecting
that I thought I don't think we really
want that really I mean I feel like when
it started going south part of that had
something to do with it yep but that was
from another actress you know it was
like it was just an actor or talking to
another actor no I couldn't really you
know yeah again fault her for that yep
for me it was like first experience with
with this this type of thing and I was
kind of learning on the fly it was like
I became smarter as the taping went on I
was like I get it wait I'm not an actor
I get to actually play myself and when
that clicked for me again and I and I
think it'll I think viewers will see
that in the show I started to own the
experience and Damon and both of us
really did and we're like you know what
all of his creativity I mean his
background and he was he went to school
to be an artist right you know all of my
experiences we started using them
like pretty aggressively to do well on
the show yeah I think that was an
important part for me to write like I
knew like that was why I wanted to do it
cuz it was zero act I was just that
could have happened in that studio that
could have happened in my office like I
was just gonna live it I was gonna give
them on the production side nothing to
edit I'm not gonna lie to you I when I
saw you on the show I was like oh my god
he's just like how he is on Instagram is
an aspiring entrepreneur you know you
grew up in a household that really
understood entertainment at the highest
levels what has been the biggest iOpener
about entrepreneurship how much work
it's a lot it's a lot of work yes
great answer a lot of work a lot of
talking to people yeah a lot of thinking
that you're making headway and then you
find out maybe not so much or there's so
many different levels to it you know
that have you realized your
communication skills is actually a
really strong conversion into this world
because of so much talking to people 100
percent mm-hmm absolutely
especially within in the room you know
because they don't operate necessarily
off of what entertainers or the
entertainment industry operates office
which is I can use this guy to you know
get money if you don't have a product
that they can use or if you're not at
that level no matter how charismatic you
are in the room they're not gonna be
like it's great to meet you awesome
actor though I loved that it was a
really he's a really good guy it's still
early for us yeah you know so so we were
hearing that and it was just kind of
like a it was an amazing experience you
know like what about um what do you
remember from staying up there before
the escalator pitch were you guys kind
of like very in your zone talking to
each other focused on a pitch or did you
get to and maybe after you were done
because you got to stay there get to
know the other other people that pitch
that day how was the how was the vibe up
there with the other nine or ten or
twelve or fifteen app developers I mean
it was both I mean on the one hand we
were we were certainly you know making
friends but honestly I could I've got
this visual of Damon because he started
our pitch going down the escalator and
he was rehearsing it
and like he took it really really
serious and and I kind of pictured him
like you know probably what he looks
like right before he's filming a movie
or doing yet doing stand-up but no man
we took it really serious and I think we
did we did quite a bit of prepping you
know there in real time and then to get
there so but also you know that
developer lounge was pretty kick ass I
mean it was like it was there wasn't a
lot of information about like when we
were gonna go so there's this the yeah
this suspense
yeah the suspense was was pretty intense
exhausting and we were there for the
entire day I think that that particular
shoot that day was a good 12 13 hours
didn't we go like second or third to
last oh my god we kept going and then
like you know kind of like cooling that
I was in a blood bath day or were people
getting picked it was like I think it
was about 50/50 maybe 40% of the of the
teams I think may have went through and
that was it to be in the circle like
what was that feeling like just being
there and we're drilling the questions
like how yeah I don't know here's well
you're there too right it was a little
fun fact I could see what you guys were
pressing but that was the last time it
was stable yes and then as soon as I got
on - no III for everybody I would watch
people be doing their thing I'm like so
yeah when we got there because we got
all Greene's initials yes and then
you're like crushing it and now we got
on there and it was going it was going
really well for a while and then
somebody said one thing and then red red
I was like yeah we're done and then
and so what's the I'm parting shots
there's a lot of aspiring entrepreneurs
and app developers listening to my
podcast Chris serial entrepreneur Damon
you know obviously growing up in an
entertainment environment now going into
entrepreneur land what's your one two
three bullets on hey keep this in mind
from me in the trenches here's the thing
that's real that I didn't expect
give me three values to leave for
everybody listening Christmas yeah I
mean its execution is bigger than your
idea so sometimes you romance your idea
and you don't take action app
development is about taking and taking
an idea and actually it's starting to
develop it yep second thing is is that
you can found an app from podunk Ville
from Scranton Pennsylvania and appear on
an apple show and you could you could
build a billion dollar company so I
think sometimes entrepreneurs give
reasons why they can't do something as a
real practical entrepreneur are you
concerned by how few people can actually
build a billion dollar company and do
you believe that the thing that was in
our blood has become so romanticized
that a lot of people that shouldn't be
entrepreneurs or jumping into the game
you know man I'm asking I'm curious I I
think that people have to fail on their
own yep so I'm cool with people taking
the first step and the reality is if
they can't execute they can't execute
the market there's a reason that
successful entrepreneurs like myself
like yourself become cereal because once
we figure out how to actually get the
job done and do it it's not to say we're
gonna succeed every time but you know
there's a recipe
yeah success leaves Clues right so but
anyway that's my second yep Daymond I
only have one which is which is to
listen and and digest and don't think
you know everything and and and to take
that in and understand that not knowing
everything is okay and I think that
helped me a lot with my with working
with Chris I'm not no it was funny they
used listen
so I maybe more than anything I don't
want to do it for a living I do quite a
bit of it made more than anything I do
being on stage and giving keynotes is
probably the place where I'm happiest
would you look happy I'm very happy
there and it's interesting I have I
don't have a set or like I don't I don't
know how to write or I'm pretty much
just kind of doing my thing but
listening is the reason I think I've
done well in entrepreneurship and on
stage like I'm reacting to what they're
reacting and I build on that is that
what you do when you do stand-up or are
you a little bit like well how do you do
it it's very interesting that you do
that because I noticed that about your
your talks is that you're very you leave
it open to the audience a lot so your
your your honestly it's like a
conversation with a bunch of people yep
with me when I do stand-up it's more I
the closest thing I'll do to that is
just reading the room yes and knowing
like okay
I don't like these kind of liking these
kind of jokes or you know I can just I
can sense it just walking in knowing you
can smell it I can smell it I can smell
when they're tight I can smell when
they're you know ready to have a good
time what's the best stand-up you've
ever had do you have an i-best yeah the
kids during night where you were like
holy [ __ ] this was like or like
something memorable like you just felt
so for me because I speak so much I some
nights are just better than others yeah
it's this it's it's the same thing I
mean some days I'll do hour-long set and
get a standing ovation and then now the
next I'll have another show an hour
later do the same set and you know
they're clapping at the end but it's
mainly because I'm done you know so but
yeah so it it I love it it is such a
it's a it's a definite high especially
when you know when they're when you feel
the audience understanding you and like
they're just going on they're hard for
you because of the brand of the last
name and the family I mean [ __ ]
absolutely I won my first year and
stand-up I went on under a different
name just so I can get my bearings you
did but did people idolize but were
people like [ __ ] dude you look exactly
like I'm inside like there's that's why
I stopped that's why it's like halfway
through my set maybe like Barry White
stuff like that so I'd have to just cut
it out all right
yeah is my name embraced it and I mean I
love it Scranton Pennsylvania yeah that
really you know I remember that I know
that that's where you came from we had
dinner years ago do you feel like that's
a very important part of your narrative
that you that you love being successful
from a place like that in a place like
that it's not like you flew to say you
know everybody then goes to Silicon
Valley you've kind of that's your that's
where you put your flag like talk to me
about that for one more second as a
parting shot dude totally 100% I believe
that I believe in in in people's
potential and I don't care if you live
in Scranton Pennsylvania or Silicon
Valley that potential realized is big
opportunity I think I just believe in
people so I've been able to do that from
Scranton spire people from Scranton may
need to become entrepreneurs to take
that first round screen and people
looking selfies with you or least like
the unofficial mayor of Scranton
um I use for the entrepreneurial
community I built a company there called
pepper Jam yep it's it's a big employer
sold it to eBay back in 2009 that was a
big deal for that community and I did it
by harnessing the 13-14 colleges and
universities from that area people were
talking about brain drain all these kids
were leaving and I said wait that's a
business model my business model is I'm
gonna harness that I'm gonna build a
company leveraging that untapped asset
and that's that was the pepper gem sort
of business you're the mayor of Scranton
pet so I am the unofficial dude I I'm
just I'm just getting started think I'm
just getting started guys thanks for
being on the podcast hey man thanks take
care thanks guys thanks for listening to
the audio experience two things one make
sure you're watching my vlog on YouTube
and to hit me up on the DM it's going
down on DM